donc j'accueille devant notre commission
d'enquête monsieur Christophe Castaner
ancien ministre de l'Intérieur qui a
accepté de faire bénéficier la
commission d'enquête de son expérience
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie au
nom de notre commission d'enquête de
votre présence parmi nous cet après-midi
un questionnaire vous a été
préalablement transmis par notre
rapporteur monsieur Florent Boudier
évidemment
nous aurons l'occasion de revenir plus
spécifiquement sur quelques points et
nous vous serions reconnaissants si dans
un second temps vous pouviez nous
apporter des réponses écrites aux
questionnaires de monsieur le rapporteur
alors comme vous le savez nous nous
penchons sur les événements violents du
printemps en marge de manifestations non
seulement en milieu urbain mais aussi en
milieu rural à la fois sur des mots
d'ordre sociaux et sur la base de
discours environnementaux
ces deux distinctions sont importantes
car les ressorts des actions ne sont pas
les mêmes bien que nous ayons appris au
cours de nos travaux que des d'Israël
existait entre ces deux problématiques
nous essayons aussi d'apprécier la
réponse des autorités publiques sous un
double prisme celui de la préservation
des droits fondamentaux d'une part et du
maintien de l'ordre public d'autre part
un monsieur le ministre avant de vous
faire prêter serment comme le veut de
l'usage il me revient de formuler les
deux premières questions qui auront en
quelque sorte vocation à introduire nos
échanges tout d'abord vous avez eu à
connaître dans vos fonctions
ministérielles des manifestations
particulièrement significatives qui
avaient la spécificité dans l'épisode
des gilets jaunes de ne pratiquement pas
être organisé ni encadré par un service
d'ordre grande différence par rapport à
ce qui se pratique habituellement
comment dans ces conditions le maintien
de l'ordre peut-il être garanti puisque
d'habitude et bien lorsqu'il y a une
déclaration préalable avec un service
d'ordre mise en commence par
l'organisation qui déclare la
manifestation et bien il y a en quelque
sorte une des échanges préalables pour
faire le nécessaire pour que tout cela
se déroule bien et donc comment
maintenir
l'ordre et avez-vous on avait vous
déduit le besoin de modifier le régime
juridique des manifestations au-delà de
ce qui avait été fait par la loi du 10
avril 2019 et puis deuxième question à
propos justement de la loi du 10 avril
2019 le Conseil constitutionnel a fait
obstacle à la création d'une
interdiction administrative de
manifester qui elle-même était issue de
cette idée de faire un parallèle avec
l'interdiction de de se rendre à des
manifestations sportives et là le
Conseil constitutionnel a considéré que
le droit de manifester un droit
fondamental avec le recul quel est le
regard que vous vous portez sur sur
cette appréciation
considérer vous toujours qu'il y a en
quelque sorte si vous me permettez
l'expression un trou dans la raquette
est-ce que le législateur devrait
reprendre sa copie pour à la fois
développer un dispositif juridique tout
en respectant évidemment les grands
principes de notre Constitution alors
monsieur le ministre avant de vous
permettre de répondre à ces premières
questions et ensuite avant de donner la
parole à Monsieur le Rapporteur puis aux
membres de la commission d'enquête qui
souhaiterait évidemment vous interroger
en application de l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance numéro
58-117 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires je vais vous demander de
prêter serment de dire la vérité toute
la vérité rien que la vérité donc si
vous pouvez brancher votre micro levez
la main droite et dire je le jure je le
jure monsieur le Président je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre et sans
tarder je vous passe la parole merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames Messieurs
les député madame messieurs je vous
remercie de m'avoir convoqué cela
formule
cet après-midi sur un sujet essentiel je
vais tenter comme je vais toujours faire
dans mes fonctions précédentes de
répondre devant la représentation
nationale à vos questions je souhaite
vous préciser tout de suite le cadre
dans le cas j'interviens de vous d'abord
vous dire que je ne suis plus ministre
de l'Intérieur depuis trois ans et que
certaines questions qui ont évoqué dans
le questionnaire qui m'a été envoyé
relève directement du ministère de
l'Intérieur et je ne suis pas en
capacité de vous répondre aujourd'hui je
prends l'exemple par exemple l'effet du
changement de doctrine de 2020
évidemment c'est une évaluation qui doit
être faite par les services du ministère
de l'intérieur mais je pense que ceux-ci
se prêteront bien évidemment à
l'exercice pour vous éclairer et de la
même façon je vais vous préciser même si
je crois beaucoup l'ont noté ma vie
politique s'est arrêtée il y a un an et
donc je n'entends pas à me prononcer
aujourd'hui sur le champ politique
j'avais il y a depuis un an à ne pas
avoir d'expression publique sur ces
différents sujets et donc dès lors que
ma parole n'est plus celle des
responsables politiques en activité il
ne m'appartient pas mais c'est pas le
sens de vos questions de me prononcer
par exemple sur les rassemblements
intervenus entre le 16 mars et mai 2023
mais je voudrais pour rebondir sur vos
questions et plus globalement sur vos
travaux j'ai écouté de nombreuses
auditions que vous avez faites et qui
étaient ouvertes à la presse ou au
public pour préparer notamment cette
réunion de maintenant je voudrais
évoquer devant vous à la fois
l'évolution du cadre du maintien de
l'ordre et les violences et maintenant
des groupuscules activistiques il me
semble c'est deux sujets qui ont
beaucoup tourné dans dans vos travaux
sur lequel je peux vous apporter un
regard un regard fondé effectivement sur
sur cette expérience d'abord monsieur le
président m'interroger sur le cadre du
maintien de l'ordre et je voudrais vous
dire combien au fond j'ai le sentiment
que la polarisation très médiatique du
moment entre soutien et détestation
autour des questions de l'ordre et
simplification avec C la réalité souvent
plus complexe et c'est jamais une
affaire de camp aux mains de tel ou
telle extrême qui s'opposent et que ça
doit appeler une sorte d'intelligence
collective minimale qui permet justement
d'avoir une réponse adaptée aux
situations et les situations sont
rarement les mêmes dans le cadre de mes
fonctions avec Laurent Nunez que vous
avez je crois additionné nous avons eu à
connaître nombreuses manifestations
évidemment les gilets jaunes mais avant
il se trouve que quelques jours après
notre prise de fonction dès le 11
novembre 2018 l'organisation du premier
Forum mondial pour la paix par le
Président de la République avait réuni à
Paris 72 chefs d'État et de gouvernement
avait été l'occasion d'une mobilisation
de la mouvance d'extrême gauche qui
avait décidé d'agir et puis un mois plus
tard vous l'avez rappelé a débuté le
mouvement des gilets jaunes le moment
des gilets jaunes se fut
55000 manifestations qui se sont
déroulées partout dans le pays
on semble oublier ce phénomène là qui
était que pour les forces de l'ordre il
a fallu répondre à tous les niveaux et
on évoquant ça je pense évidemment aux
forces spécialisées aux escadron au CRS
mais aussi à la gendarmerie du village
du coin qui devait faire face à des
événements auxquels elle n'était pas
forcément habitué et puis nous avons à
connaître aussi des événements comme
l'organisation du G7 à Biarritz sans
doute 2018 qui mobilisa à l'époque
l'international du désordre comme c'est
le cas de façon systématique depuis
Seattle en 1990 il faut avoir à l'esprit
que maintenir l'ordre c'est et vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président de
votre question
maintenir un équilibre entre d'une part
la sécurité de tous nos concitoyens mais
aussi celle des manifestants évidemment
qui sont des citoyens actifs à ce
moment-là et qu'il faut évidemment
protéger tout comme il faut protéger les
biens et les institutions et d'autre
part la protection de la liberté celle
de manifester
de s'exprimer et de contester et c'est
une question d'équilibre qui est
toujours mouvant et il dépend des
périodes des pratiques des expériences
des types de troubles auxquels les
forces de sécurité intérieure sous
l'autorité des préfets doivent faire
face le maintien de l'ordre et c'est une
certitude n'est jamais une chose aisée
sauf pour les professionnels des
plateaux télé mais confrontés à la
réalité c'est un tout petit peu
différent dans certains cas il impose le
recours à la force bien sûr son usage
doit être proportionné à l'atteinte à
l'ordre public mais j'insiste toutefois
sur le fait que ce n'est pas parce qu'il
y a usage de la force qu'il y aurait
faute il faut que les choses soient
claires le record à la force est parfois
nécessaire et cette nécessité doit bien
évidemment être justifiée en faisant un
usage maîtrisé de la force ou des armes
le cas échéant pour faire face aux
violences et le débat qui existe dans
l'opinion publique dans le milieu
politique depuis plusieurs années sur
ces sujets et parfaitement légitime
et l'évolution à connaître de façon
presque constante elle est légitime
aussi parce que les formes de
contestation changent et ont changé je
crois tout à l'heure que vous
auditionnez le préfet Delpech et il a pu
évoquer ces moments où le dialogue
systématique réel entre les
organisateurs des manifestations et les
forces de l'ordre exister mais c'était
autrefois il n'en reste plus grand chose
il faut même avoir en tête que
quelquefois le principe même de
l'organisation partagée et refuser par
nature et on touche par exemple là une
des vraies difficultés liées à la
question de la désescalade la
désescalade est un principe qui doit
rassembler chacun mais pour qu'il y ait
des escalades il faut qu'il y ait des
forces de l'ordre il faut en face un
organisateur des interlocuteurs avec
lesquels on peut arriver à parler et
souvent ça n'est pas le cas et en
particulier quand les manifestations ne
sont pas déclarées ce fut le cas pour
98% des manifestations que j'évoquais
dans mon propre polyminaire y compris
celle des gilets jaunes ces manif à
l'ancienne excusez moi du propos il y a
pas de nostalgie sur ce sujet c'est
juste un référentiel historique avait
des interlocuteurs avec lesquels on
pouvait dialoguer ça n'est plus le cas
actuellement en même temps je voudrais
insister sur le fait que il n'y a pas de
nouveautés dans la violence ou du moins
il y a une forme d'ancienneté sur ces
violences-là depuis Seattle en 1998
1990 il n'y a pas eu un sommet européen
international sans mobilisation et
quelquefois souvent sans violence on se
souvient aussi du sommet de l'OTAN à
Strasbourg ou un quartier entier avait
été dévasté c'était en 2009 et nous
avons aujourd'hui un phénomène très
régulièrement pour constater de
personnes ayant la volonté de commettre
des exasations violentes qui s'immisent
dans les cortèges et même si c'est pas
l'ensemble des manifestants ils sont
souvent victimes aussi de ces violences
c'est un phénomène que nous connaissons
c'est la technique désormais tristement
célèbre des Black Blocs qui n'est pas
seulement la panache des moulle des
mouvements d'ultra gauche en France
j'évoquais Strasbourg on peut mais vous
l'avez sûrement déjà travaillé évoquer
les manifestations sur les lois el
khomri les 1er mai 2017 les premiers mai
2018 et on l'a vu aussi vous avez posé
la question directement au moment des
mouvements des gilets jaunes ou certains
ultra jeunes je reprends le vocabulaire
des services de la police leur jargon on
les a vu recourir aux techniques des
black blocks et l'organiser le propager
de façon très systématisée et
aujourd'hui on voit que ça peut toucher
toutes les villes et tous les cortèges
il y a une autre mutation qui est
particulièrement importante et qui a un
effet sur les manifestations c'est la
diffusion des images sur les réseaux
sociaux et sur les chaînes d'information
continue les casseurs ont désormais une
caisse de résonance et un public et
quelquefois même quand le mouvement est
faible ce fut très vite le cas sur la
mobilisation pour les gilets jaunes
quelques dizaines de milliers de
personnes des actes 3 la violence a
dominé totalement l'espace médiatique
qu'elle a Sat et donc nos forces
aujourd'hui sont confrontées à des
mouvements extrêmement violents et qui
se disperse qui échappe à la
manifestation et peuvent prendre
possibles tel ou telle bâtiment
institutionnels en tête par exemple la
préfecture de Haute-Loire quand elle a
été incendiée par des manifestants le
1er décembre 2018 Jean tête aussi des
choses plus structurées plus organisées
des commandos qui étaient organisés le
soir la nuit pour prendre
pour brûler des péages par exemple mais
aussi des lieux de pouvoir dans
l'évolution à laquelle que j'ai eu à
connaître je voudrais évoquer la gestion
de l'évacuation de Notre-Dame-des-Landes
je sais pas si c'est un sujet sur lequel
vous avez pu travailler ça avait permis
des avancées fortes en matière de
maintien de l'ordre notamment sur
l'utilisation des nouvelles technologies
en particulier les drones c'était avant
l'encadrement légal la discussion
l'annulation puis le nouveau texte
l'utilisation de nouvelles technologies
autre la judiciarisation plus
systématique afin de nouveau dans la
gestion du maintien de l'ordre et là je
dirigation plus systématique individus
violents c'est des choses qu'on a eu à
connaître et puis il y a eu la semaine
qui a suivi le premier décembre 2018 qui
a été une étape importante au-delà du
cadre légal sur lequel on met interrogé
mais où avec Laurent nunel et je vous
rappelle pas le premier décembre l'Arc
de Triomphe nous avons décidé de changer
dans la semaine entre le premier lui
décembre en profondeur la doctrine
d'emploi pour la rendre beaucoup plus
réactive être réactif ça signifie quoi
ça signifie être en mesure d'interpeller
immédiatement les fauteurs de troubles
de mettre un terme rapidement aux
exigations commises contre les personnes
les biens ou les institutions et pour
cela on avait souhaité accroître la
mobilité la réactivité l'autonomie aussi
la taille des groupes qui interviennent
pour la gestion de l'ordre pour faire
cesser un trouble et pour répondre à ces
nouveaux schémas d'organisation de
manifestants plus violent ou aux
violents systématique que j'évoquais
dans mon propos précédent je voudrais
donner une précision tout de suite nous
n'avons pas abandonné la doctrine du
maintien de l'ordre à distance pour
passer à cette doctrine de réactivité
d'intervention la doctrine du maintien
de l'ordre à distance à ce moment-là
comme dans le schéma national du
maintien de l'ordre qui était adopté
depuis reste la doctrine principale nous
sommes seulement dans le cas où on est
confronté à des violences sur des
modalités d'intervention qui sont
différentes et qui permettent d'agir
mais en l'absence de violence les forces
de l'ordre encadrent évidemment les
manifestations à distance et cette règle
n'a jamais évolué ces dernières années
elle n'a pas évolué au moment où on se
parle il y a une troisième évolution
après le 16 mars 2019 et les incidents
qui ont lieu selon immédiate aussi des
forces de sécurité intérieure et ça
c'est l'objectif de disloquer ces
groupes à risque dès le début c'est dans
ce cadre là que nous avons géré la crise
après l'automne 2019 avec Laurent on a
voulu aller plus loin réfléchir à froid
à la doctrine tel que nous l'avons
adapté à partir du 1er décembre 19 et un
travail important avait été mené avec un
collectif avec des professionnels des
praticiens du terrain des journalistes
certaines associations comme la Ligue
des droits de l'homme ou à ministère
international et à l'époque le
défenseurs des droits et c'est aussi
dans ce cadre et celui du Livre blanc
que nous avions organisé au début de
l'année 2020 une convention citoyenne
avec des Français représentants tous les
territoires de la nation toutes les CSP
pendant plusieurs week-end sur la
thématique du rapport entre la police et
les citoyens parce que nous savions que
ce rapport était interrogé même si ça ne
m'est pas en cause le soutien
significatif des Français alors force de
sécurité intérieure c'est dans ce cadre
là qu'on commençait à être mis en avant
des choses qui ont été retenues ensuite
comme le binôme d'équipe de liaison et
d'information c'était une demande à
l'époque express du président de la
République de s'inspirer en faisant du
benchmark depuis étranger de la
possibilité d'avoir ce cadre de dialogue
pas toujours facile à vivre mais je
pense que c'est une bonne chose je
parlais tout à l'heure de la
judiciarisation c'était l'intégration
plus forte du dispositif judiciaire dans
ces moments là la fiche d'interpellation
ou PV d'interpellation je sais plus quel
est le terme exact qui sont des outils
efficaces mais lourds en matière de
gestion de l'ordre public dans les
années que nous avons connues avant on
se préoccupait pas forcément
d'interpeller on se préoccuper de
neutraliser les désormais pas forcément
des suites judiciaires aujourd'hui
évidemment nous sommes dans un rapport
différent permettez-moi monsieur le
Président de basculer du coup maintenant
sur les évolutions des forces radicales
de notre pays je crois que la plupart
d'entre vous ont dû à l'excellente
interview du DGSI ce week-end dans le
monde qui est clair je crois aussi vos
travaux et je crois qu'il est important
de distinguer l'extrémisme politique de
sa forme activiste mon premier sur
l'extrémisme politique ne serait qu'un
triste constat des graves dommages causé
à notre démocratie par les populistes
toujours en tout genre qui à mon sens ne
se rendent pas compte que en ce moment
l'antagonisme permanent dans le débat
politique
il crée y compris au sein de l'assemblée
que j'observe avec une certaine distance
aujourd'hui un champ de guerre qui se
traduira par un champ de ruine mais
c'est pas le sujet de votre travaux vos
travaux c'est plutôt sur la forme active
ou la mouvance ultra sur ce qui
considèrent que la violence est un moyen
légitime pour faire valoir ses idées et
cela sont d'une autre nature l'actimisme
violent se traduit sous trois formes les
troubles à l'ordre public l'action
clandestine l'action terroriste seul la
première forme et le sujet de votre
commission mais si j'évoque ces trois
formes c'est parce que si l'un ne
conduit pas naturellement à l'autre la
hiérarchie de la gravité des liens
peuvent exister et comme je crois que
l'histoire est souvent un cycle on a vu
des extrêmes gauche extrêmement violente
qui pourrait le redevenir même si
aujourd'hui elles sont fortes puissantes
mais pas forcément allant jusqu'à des
actes d'assassinat tel qu'on a pu les
connaître dans les années 70 et 80 en
synthèse la menace véhiculée par les
mouvements subversifs radicales tant
aussi à s'amplifier depuis plusieurs
années je crois que ce phénomène est
alimenté par plusieurs facteurs alors
notamment la banalisation et la
propagation dans la sphère publique de
discours empreinte de radicalité et
d'idées complotistes mais aussi la
grande sensibilité des mouvances
radicales aux crises nationales
internationales crise des gilets jaunes
la crise du covid la guerre en Ukraine
sont des effets qui alimentent aussi
éradiquer là nous pourrons si vous le
souhaitez évoquer plus longuement
l'influence de la vie politique ou de
certains partis moi je pense que la
décomplexification totale de la haine
raciale portée de plateaux de télé en
plateau télé par exemple pendant la
campagne présidentielle par ex Zemmour
ou la conflictualisation permanente des
discours de fi ne sont sûrement pas sans
effet aussi sur ces radicalité
mon sentiment est que le modèle
démocratique aujourd'hui est
sérieusement sauvagement quelquefois
sévèrement contesté par une frange ultra
radicalisée de la population qui
s'exprime avec davantage de violences et
apparaît désormais convaincu de
l'éventuelle recours à la violence pour
se faire entendre du côté de
l'ultra-droite sous le savez c'est le
moment ce qui est éminemment composite
qui agrège des individus et si de
courant idéologique extrêmement variés
tels que l'ultra-nationalisme nos
fascisme le néo patriotisme ou le
racialisme mais il se retrouve toujours
sur une idée commune celle d'un
communautarisme blanc et la peur du
grand remplacement et la mouvance
aujourd'hui est très fortement renforcée
par les tests conspirationnistes et
complotistes et du coup ça génère cette
décomplexion que nous avons pu constater
par exemple le 9 mai et la manif du 6
mai le collecte le comité du 9 mai et la
manif du 6 mai ou effectivement ils se
sont affirmés comme pour l'hommage assez
Bastien des yeux mais c'est une
manifestation provocatrice mais sans
débordement et on a vu par contre des
mobilisations de cette
ultra droite
qui a été qui a pris des formes de
contestation beaucoup plus violentes
notamment sur les cadavres on a tous en
tête Saint-Brevin-les-Pins mais il y a
lac en région parisienne divergel
grignons où on voit là les violences
très présentes et montée en puissance je
crois que aujourd'hui l'ultra droite et
galvanisé et elle s'attache même
d'ailleurs à lutter contre des
événements qu'elle estime décadents
notamment en lien avec la communauté
LGBT on a vu leur mobilisation se pour
empêcher un concert de Bilal Hassani
même si sur l'ultra droite on retrouve
les les cibles classiques le musulman le
Juif l'immigré le franc-maçon et
l'ennemi de gauche et c'est toujours
présent aussi dans les manifestations
quand il y a une confrontation
je crois qu'en plus il y a un phénomène
qui aggrave tout cela c'est l'influence
suprémaciste anglo-saxonne qui pousse la
trait vers les armes à feu et qui
donnent plus de dangerosité encore au
phénomène on a vu Frédéric clignool en
2020 sans parler d'un fusil automatique
et d'un Glock et tué trois gendarmes qui
aujourd'hui je le dis est au panthéon de
l'ultra droite malgré le caractère
insupportable de ce qu'il a fait
l'ultra gauche elle est aussi très
éclairé
dans une volonté forte de s'opposer à
l'état
on sait bien que les menaces on est sur
chaque mode plus classique les menaces
véculées par l'ultra gauche quand elle
avait essentiellement de l'ordre public
et concerne en principe plutôt la teinte
au bien qu'aux personnes malgré toujours
une volonté inébranlable de de taper les
militants d'extrême droite si l'occasion
se présente les activistes d'ultra
gauche ont des méthodes différentes qui
cherchent à se greffer à des
manifestations qui sont en général
incapables d'organiser et ils cherchent
à aller pénétrer dans le but de
l'éradicaliser de les faire dégénérer
dans une perspective insurrectionnelle
depuis le début des années 2000 on l'a
vu à plusieurs reprises j'évoquais
quelques rendez-vous on pourrait aussi
citer les mobilisations de contestation
contre le CPE en 2016 ou la loi travail
en 2006 pour le CP le CPE ou la loi
travail en 2016 le premier acte et je
conclue mon propos sur ce sujet avant de
répondre directement à la question que
ça en évolution législative le premier
les premiers actes du mouvement des
gilets jaunes ont été le terrain de
l'ultra-droite d'ailleurs dès le 24
novembre j'avais évoqué les séditieux
d'ultra-droites ça mettait sérieusement
reproché j'avais d'ailleurs critiqué
Marine Le Pen qui avait interrogé sur le
pourquoi on ne rassemblait pas et on
autorisait pas les rassemblements sur
l'âme de Triomphe et les Champs-Élysées
mais ce qui est intéressant dans le
sujet je veux pas te propose politique
sur ça dans le sujet que vous intéresse
c'est de voir comment les premiers actes
étaient ceux de l'ultra-droite et
d'ailleurs vous souvenez certainement de
cette une involontaire semble-t-il de
Paris Match du 6 décembre qui mettait en
scène Hervé là lundi reset
récent une bombe artisanale devant l'Arc
de Triomphe il avait été rejet par
rejoint par Yvon Benedetti et donc ils
ont tenu les premiers actes et puis
ultra gauche qui au début une participe
pas à ça on pourrait évoquer les raisons
pour lesquelles les participants se dire
il y a une opportunité avec la stratégie
du Coucou de l'ultra gauche qui consiste
à aller dans un mouvement global et à
vouloir le faire dégénérer et donc dès
l'acte 4 l'ultra gauche s'est battu dans
les rues face à ceux qui étaient
mobilisés de l'ultra-droite à gagner et
ensuite à occuper l'espace pendant la
suite des manifestations faut avoir en
tête qu'il était aussi difficile à
l'époque de distinguer les casseurs des
gilets jaunes radicalisés et des
éléments d'extrême droite et d'extrême
gauche qui à un moment donné tout ce
petit monde se retrouver à l'aigrement
pour marcher ensemble dans la rue on a
vu les dernières évolutions je peux être
rapide là-dessus concernant l'ultra
gauche c'est la récupération notamment
des causes environnementales ça ne
solide l'a montré mais c'est pas un
phénomène totalement nouveau faut se
souvenir par exemple de la campagne de
sabotage de tous les relais télé 5G qui
avait été organisé et plusieurs
centaines en France avaient été
mobilisés donc là aussi il y a ces
formes de mobilisation pour terminer mon
propos introductif
sur la question de l'évolution
législative d'abord sur beaucoup de
points que je viens d'évoquer ça n'est
pas à partir d'une évolution légative ou
d'un texte que nous avons décidé de
bouger et puis il y a eu une opportunité
législative sur un texte qui était porté
par le groupe LR au Sénat et par Bruno
retaillod sur la gestion de l'ordre
public dans lequel effectivement il y
avait cette interdiction de paraître qui
aboutit au texte de la loi du premier
avril 2019
je dis que je dirais toute la vérité et
puis j'ai une liberté politique
aujourd'hui qui me permet de vous dire
que pour moi c'était pas un sujet
essentiel
il n'était pas absolument indispensable
il était donc coeur du texte le groupe
Air qui portait ce texte à l'origine du
Sénat étonné et donc je n'avais pas de
problème de fond pour le faire c'est une
pratique je veux pas de problème de fond
parce qu'en terme de liberté publique
elle se pratique dans le sport et donc
franchement vu ce qu'on a vécu je
pensais qu'elle pouvait se pratiquer
mais la réalité est que nous connaissons
à peu près les 2000 militants
d'ultra-droite en France et les 3000 on
est passé à 3000 ça progresse d'ultra
gauche les services les connaissent
généralement quand il y a une
manifestation ils sont identifiés ils
sont repérés et cela se comporte jamais
mal
parce qu'ils savent très bien que ils
ont à proximité des forces de sécurité
intérieure par contre ils organisent ces
systèmes ils les alimentent ils
utilisent les réseaux sociaux il les
poussent mais cela sont pas directement
les principaux casseurs cette mesure si
elle avait été adoptée et validée par le
Sénat aurait permis de mettre de côté
les plus abrutis de ces violences mais
pas les leaders et d'ailleurs c'est
souvent la difficulté dans les
interpellations c'est qu'on interpelle
ce qui est court moins vite et donc
c'était une mesure qui aurait été utile
qui aurait permis au préfet sous
l'autorité du juge de prendre des
décisions de l'interdiction de paraître
elle n'a pas été retenue ça n'a pas pour
répondre à votre question est un élément
neutralisant l'action de nos forces de
ces empêchant l'action de nos forces de
sécurité intérieure voilà monsieur le
Président désolé d'avoir été un peu long
dans ce propos liminaire non merci
Monsieur Miss ça permet effectivement de
poser le contexte juste un élément de
précision un moment donné dans votre
propos
vous dites que vous avez été amené et
vous citiez je crois le cas du du
Fouquet à faire en sorte que on puisse
le plus tôt possible
disloquer les groupes à risque
ceci enfin des débuts ou du moins dès
lors que on voit que le risque est avéré
ce qui ressort de nos auditions c'est
que ce que l'on peut qualifier de Black
Bloc le phénomène est de plus en plus
massif c'est-à-dire que tout à l'heure
préfère Delpech
faisait référence alors j'ai pu en tête
la date précise de la manifestation mais
les services avaient remonté en quelque
sorte une une prévision de la présence
de 800 personnes de type black bloc et
en réalité il furent 1400 et donc en
fait là où je voudrais que vous nous
éclairiez un petit peu
c'est que ce phénomène semble quand même
de plus en plus massif enfin quand vous
avez
1400 personnes susceptibles d'être
ultra violentes
comment pouvez-vous procéder à une
dislocation puisque en réalité on est là
par rapport à quelque chose qui qui
revient une intensité très très forte
puisque plus du tout 30 40 50 ou même
une centaine là on est à plusieurs
plusieurs dizaines de de centaines et là
ça commence à être quand même très très
difficile donc on voit bien qu'il y a ce
premier effet donc
comment comment en fait
faire face à cela et puis ensuite il y a
autre chose vous l'avez évoqué et très
très largement aussi dans votre propos
c'est que
il y a une contestation de la
manifestation organisée c'est-à-dire il
a aussi on faisait référence au fait que
et bien par rapport à une manifestation
organisée il y avait un pré-cortège en
quelque sorte donc 20 000 dans la
manifestation organisée et 14000 en
quelque sorte en précortège et donc là
évidemment
14.000 personnes qui refusent de quelque
sorte de rentrer dans les je dirais dans
les règles habituelles et bien ça
devient on imagine de plus en plus
difficilement gérable pour les forces de
l'ordre
d'abord un mot sur les black-box je
pense que vous avez eu l'occasion de
parler des spécialistes du sujet mais la
difficulté du Black Box c'est que ça
n'est pas contrairement à ce que
certains pensent pouvoir disent des
personnes bien identifiées qu'on connaît
bien qui se donne rendez-vous pour
le bordel si ça marche comme ça
ce serait assez simple la réalité c'est
que ce sont je vais être provocateur
mais je veux dire nos enfants
ce sont nos enfants qui à un moment
donné décide d'aller dans un mouvement
contestataire pour une cause qu'il juge
noble et qui du coup participent à un
moment donné à une forme de radicalité
moi qui suis un vieil élu local j'ai
souvenir de je veux dire la pharmacienne
par hasard qui au moment des élections
européennes alors qu'elle votaient
traditionnellement toujours à droite aux
élections européennes aller voter pour
nouveau partie antique capitaliste et le
petit moment de folie et hop voilà il y
avait une émotion en réalité aujourd'hui
il y a des jeunes qui confrontés à des
sujets dont il trouve qu'ils sont
déterminants pour leur propre avenir ou
pour l'avenir de la planète
considère que il faut cette expression
et je juge pas en disant ça et donc du
coup vont participer j'étais très
impressionné quand on interpellait
certains acteurs d'actes très violents
pendant les manifestations des gilets
jaunes
quand on les interpellait chez eux on
s'aperçonnait qu'on avait des étudiants
brillants qui n'avaient aucun CV aucun
élément de leur tâche et qui du coup
participaient à ça et donc d'une semaine
sur l'autre d'une manifestation sur
l'autre ce sont des gens extrêmement
différents par contre il y a un coeur et
l'évolution en fait que nous avons
proposé avec Laurent Nunez après le 16
mars était de dire dès la constitution
du cœur en intervient quand vous avez
effectivement 1600 personnes qui sont en
position de combat à ce moment-là et
vous êtes en pleine ville c'est pas deux
camps qui doivent s'opposer et c'est pas
une logique de guerre et donc il faut
traiter de façon différente faut essayer
de limiter la mobilité du groupe mais
vous allez pas directement
l'interpellation dès que vous avez le
début de la constitution du cœur qui va
agréger ensuite jusqu'à 1600 personnes
pour prendre l'exemple du préfet Delpech
si vous intervenez avant à 30 sur le
facteur déclenchant à ce moment-là et
que vous traitez le facteur déclenchant
le collectif n'arrive pas à s'organiser
je dois un exemple très précis
j’évoquais tout à l'heure le premier
forum pour la paix la manifestation
était organisée place de la République
je vous le dis parce que c'est un
apprentissage pour moi
le principe du Black Bloc était de faire
le tour de la place de la République en
accélérant le dispositif pour de temps
en temps pouvoir taper sur les forces de
sécurité ou les institutions ou les
banques ou les commerces qui étaient là
en fait on a fait un système très simple
on a on a mis des véhicules des objets
en quinconce pour empêcher un mouvement
dynamique et au fond ce sont toutes ces
méthodes là que nos forces de sécurité
sous l'autorité des préfets maîtrise
parfaitement qui permettent d'intervenir
donc pour répondre très concrètement
votre question l'évolution de la
doctrine est effectivement de tenter
avant la commission de l'acte mais dès
la constitution du phare qui est le
Black Bloc alors maintenant le parapluie
noir ou le fait qu'on s'habille
totalement moi quand il y a le cœur à 30
personnes de neutraliser ce cœur
immédiatement de le casser sans
forcément arrêter les gens mais de le
faire se répartir différemment et ça a
montré son efficacité mais ça ne permet
pas systématiquement de gagner le
rapport de force qui se crée à ce
moment-là
la contestation de la manifestation
désorganisée
c'est effectivement un vrai problème
mais je crois que de toute façon c'est
un problème face auquel nous devons être
une manifestation interdite il n'est pas
interdit d'y aller et donc à partir de
là de toute façon vous ne pouvez pas
être dans la situation de dire je vais
embarquer tout le monde je t'ai
confronté à ce sujet j'ai eu le droit de
nombreuses critiques au moment suite au
décès de cette américain
souffle avec grandissent sous les
l'étouffement de policiers il y a une
grande mobilisation mondiale et elle a
eu lieu à Paris et c'était quelques
jours après
la fin du confinement elle a été
spectaculaire parce que je pense que
c'est aussi lié au confinement mais
l'émotion mondial que nous avons connue
il y avait près de 30 000 personnes qui
ont manifesté très jeunes
et je me souviens avoir fait une
matinale le matin ou on m'a dit mais
elle interdite il faut l'empêcher et je
les propos en disant mais il faut aussi
prendre en compte les réalités cette
manifestation d'ailleurs ne s'est pas
mal passée même s'il y a eu des
tentatives d'intrusion dans le palais de
justice que nous avons neutralisé mais
j'ai dit mais la loi elle doit
s'appliquer aussi avec une forme
d'intelligence et je pense que là aussi
il faut faire la différence entre les
manifestations
non déclarées
voir interdite et la réaction des forces
de l'ordre nous ne sommes pas en mesure
aujourd'hui de toute façon pour nos
forces de sécurité de dire on va mettre
10 000 policiers qui vont arrêter tout
le monde mettre tout le monde en garde à
vue pendant 24 heures on va régler le
problème c'est du pipeau ça n'existe pas
et donc là dessus il faut avoir une
approche pragmatique ça n'est pas une
doctrine mais je pense que c'est
efficace
merci beaucoup monsieur ministre donc je
vais passer la parole à Monsieur le
rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre la commission d'enquête ne
porte pas sur la période où vous étiez
ministre et doit-on non pas de vous des
réponses
aussi circonstancié que le pourrait le
faire l'exécutif aujourd'hui et donc
c'est plutôt à la fois une prise
d'expérience
témoignage de votre part qu'une audition
en réalité à proprement parler
dans les quelques éléments que j'avais
en tête en vous écoutant
quand on regarde la situation à
Sainte-Souline un argument est souvent
donné dans les auditions que nous avons
pu
exercer ces dernières semaines au fond
le problème vient de la de
l'interdiction même de la manifestation
si l'État n'avait pas interdit la
manifestation alors les choses serait
bien passé comment vous réagissez à ce
type d'argument pas important d'avoir
votre regard sur ce genre d'argument
deuxième question plus technique
et pour sur la question des forces des
forces intermédiaires des moyens
intermédiaires la mise à distance les
moyens intermédiaires comment on vous
appréciez cette situation l'état des
moyens intermédiaires leur évolution
éventuelle qu'elle regarde portez-vous
sur ce sujet et puis une troisième
question qui est évoquée d'ailleurs par
le DGSI Nicolas dernier dans son dans
son interview au journal Le Monde
il y a et est-ce que sont des éléments
dont vous aviez connaissance à l'époque
il y a aujourd'hui semble-t-il un risque
relativement important
d'affrontement entre ultra droite et
ultra gauche dont d'ailleurs la séquence
que nous étudions celle du 16 mars Au
mois de mai pourrait être une forme
d'accélérateur avec cet argument qui
évoqué Nicolas Lerner alors c'était à
huis clos mais je le dis parce que il a
depuis eu des propos publics donc on
peut se permettre de les évoquer cette
idée au fond que l'ultra gauche aurait
pris la rue
aurait gagné la rue à travers un certain
nombre de prix cortège de violence qui
ont été exercées ces dernières semaines
ces derniers mois et qu'il y a une
volonté désormais de l'ultra-doua
d'aller au combat vers l'ultra gauche
est-ce que c'est un risque dont vous
aviez connaissance à l'époque de vos
fonctions et comment vous appréciez
cette observation qui a été faite par le
DGSI qui est plutôt à l'armiste sur à la
fois l'évolution du dragon et j'entends
ce que vous avez dit sur la cause
environnementaliste forme d'infiltration
et sur le risque d'affrontement avec le
bras droit merci monsieur le rapporteur
je vous repasse tout de suite la parole
monsieur le ministre
Sainte-Soline c'est la cause de
l'interdiction
ça me fait penser au fait que souvent
j'ai eu en responsabilité l'occasion
d'entendre des reproches qui m'étaient
fait par des mers sur la gestion de
l'ordre public et souvent j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire mais il y a pas de
problème si vous souhaitez qu'à la
prochaine manifestation nous
désengageons la totalité des forces de
sécurité intérieure qui serait la cause
des désordres que vous évoquez et que
dans votre commune il est zéro force de
sécurité intérieure et on va faire toute
confiance pour organiser à des escalades
dites le moi je n'ai jamais eu de
retours positif à cette suggestion et
donc je crois que il faut poser la
question des conséquences de
l'interdiction de la conscience de
l'équipement de la conséquence de
l'intervention et il faut interroger les
modalités de gestion de droit public de
toute façon en permanente
la situation actuelle n'est pas
satisfaisante de toute façon et donc
évidemment elle devra encore évoluer
mais je crois que ceux qui se contentent
de considérer que la cause c'est
l'interdiction sont les mêmes qui
tiennent les discours qui justifient ou
qui excuse d'action violente et qui du
coup contribue à la banaliser pour moi
l'action violente et violente la loi
c'est la loi quand on met à sac une
école quand on met un sac un commerce
pour moi ça relève d'une interdiction
liée à la loi ensuite on va avoir un
jugement de valeur sur le sujet mais
dans les deux cas c'est interdit par la
loi et jamais je n'accepte qu'on puisse
encourager à ne pas respecter cette loi
sur les moyens intermédiaires et le
matériel ça fait partie des sujets
on a fait je me souviens avoir fait
travailler notamment dans la préparation
du nouveau schéma sur du benchmark
international on a quelques fois évoqué
les chevaux même en Angleterre la
technique de protection des chevaux a
évolué parce que certains aient pris
l'habitude de couper les jarrés des
chevaux et donc la violence de toute
façon sur les différentes formes de
protection et différentes en Allemagne
on utilise beaucoup plus les engins
lanceurs d'eau de façon massive et je
France on utilise peu
peut-être que
un sujet qui peut évoluer puis ensuite
il y a les outils qu'on utilise ou les
armes qu'on utilise j'ai interdit les
Gly F4
les GF4 avaient une vraie efficacité
c'était des grenades qui permettaient
dans un moment où un fonctionnaire de
nos forces de sécurité 61 acculée de
pouvoir l'utiliser avec une très forte
explosion la cause de l'explosion
c'était de l'explosif et il y a eu un
certain nombre d'accidents graves quasi
systématiquement liée au fait que des
manifestants prenant dans la main la
gdf4 pour leur envoyer sur les forces de
sécurité intérieure vous voyez
l'explosion au moment où il la prenait
dans la main il démarre arracher
je pense que la solution la plus simple
est d'éviter de prendre
de la grenade explosive et de la
renvoyer sur les forces sécurité
intérieure mais j'ai fait le choix
d'interdire avec BF4 nous en avions en
stock près de 80 000 et nous avons
neutralisé le stock de près de 80 000 et
puis il y a d'autres outils comme le LBD
qui a fait débat je rappelle que au mois
de janvier 2019 c'est à dire quelques
jours après le démarrage j'avais
expressément demandé par une autre
circulaire aux policiers des gendarmes
faisaient déjà de déclencher
systématiquement sauf légitime défense
dans des proportions délais extrêmement
courtes les caméras à piétons et nous
aurons pu constater une baisse
significative du nombre de tirs le
principe du LBD c'est de tenir à
distance une foule qui est agressive
c'est pas de tirer sur quelqu'un qui ne
présente pas dangerosité particulière
par contre c'est une arme qui permet
d'éviter dans certains cas l'utilisation
d'une arme létale et donc c'est un sujet
aussi mais je comprends votre
interrogation je pense de toute façon la
technologie et le matériel évoluant il
faut faire évoluer et il faut quelque
part avoir des hommes spécialisés et
formés qui respectent une doctrine
extrêmement stricte et qui soit
contrôlée un tiers de LBD chez les
gendarmes doit être autorisé par le chef
du groupe d'interventions avant le tiers
je pense que il y a des dispositifs qui
peuvent encore monter en puissance sur
ce sujet sur les risques d'affrontement
entre
ultra-droite ultra gauche d'abord ça
fait partie de la mythologie de ces
groupes
c'est c'est la cerise sur le gâteau du
combat et donc très régulièrement une
partie
ultra gauche est composée en deux
grandes familles les antifas font partie
d'une de ces familles c'est la moitié
des effectifs et s'organise ce structure
dans la volonté de casser du fasciste et
donc ça fait partie de leur mythologie
de leur acte j'évoquais les gilets
jaunes où on a vu la bascule et on a vu
en tête mais c'est pas très intéressant
les lieux où d'ailleurs les
confrontations les affrontements
s'étaient fait et la bascule d'une ultra
gauche qui l'a emporté sur l'ultra
droite à partir de l'acte 3 ou de l'acte
4 dans la rue c'est phénomènes montent
en puissance et la radicalité de ces
fenêtres montant puissance ce que je
sais c'est que au moment où on se parle
l'ultra droite présente une dangerosité
en haut de spectre c'est-à-dire sur le
risque terroriste plus élevé que l'ultra
gauche mais comme je le dis tout à
l'heure sur mon approche par cycle vous
pouvez des phénomènes qui font que la
radicalité peut venir elle a exister
chez l'ultra gauche elle n'est plus au
même niveau de violence aujourd'hui elle
peut revenir je crois que Nicolas Lerner
a rappelé que depuis 2017 10 attentats
terroristes issus de l'extrême droite
ont été neutralisées un seul du côté de
l'ultra gauche mais je crois que
les tensions que nous connaissons
contribuent à cela pour répondre à ces
sujets je pense que les dissolutions
d'associations sont importantes j'ai
souvenir d'avoir dissoudre comme comme
blood and honor hexagone comme le
bastion social comme combat 18 j'ai lu
un papier dans Libération qui faisait
état du fait que je l'ai en le voyant
dans Libération que j'avais dissous un
grand nombre d'associations toutes
d'ultra-droites d'extrême droite ou lié
à la mouvance terroriste islamique
et que nous n'avons eu aucun recours qui
nous a fait perdre sur ces sujets
mais je pense que c'est aussi une façon
d'agir et de permettre de neutraliser ce
risque là je rajoute un dernier point
puisque vous étonnez Nicolas Lerner le
sujet du renseignement est majeur nous
avons connu sur une échelle de 15 ans
une faiblesse du renseignement le
renseignement remonte en puissance et
aujourd'hui
présente une capacité d'information et
d'intervention de très haut niveau j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure le sommet de
Biarritz si nous avons réussi avec
Laurent Nunez la gestion du sommet de
Biarritz c'est parce que le
renseignement a été d'une très très
grande efficacité et la coopération
internationale aussi a été d'une grande
efficacité
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre je
vais passer à la parole à Madame Diaz
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur monsieur le ministre parmi
les éléments que nous déplorons à
l'occasion des manifestations déclarées
ou non déclarées mais dans la période
qui nous occupe ce sont les slogans
antiflic qui revêtent une violence
inouïe et il faut le dire les forces de
l'ordre sont épuisées leurs morales est
en berne elles expriment régulièrement
un malaise profond et récemment la Cour
des comptes a pointé du doigt la grande
démission au sein de la police nationale
la crise d'évocations et les difficultés
à fidéliser les effectifs cet épuisement
physique mais aussi moral ne date pas
d'hier et
moi je j'ai envie de vous poser la
question est-ce que le point de bascule
n'a pas eu lieu en juin 2020 quand vous
étiez ministre de l'Intérieur et je vais
vous rappeler des événements qui ont
marqué toutes les forces de l'ordre dans
toutes les villes de France moi je me
souviens j'étais aux des forces de
l'ordre à Bordeaux c'est quand les
policiers ont jeté leur menottes à terre
pour exprimer leurs sentiments le
sentiment d'être lâché des avoué jeter
en pâture par la hiérarchie et donc
c'est à partir de ce moment-là que je
vous pose la question est-ce que c'est
pas à partir de ce moment-là que chez
les forces de l'ordre à l'encontre des
forces de l'ordre il y a pas eu une
porte ouverte
vis-à-vis de la criminalisation que l'on
fait régulièrement à leur rencontre
est-ce que c'est pas à partir de là
qu'il y a eu un sentiment de
galvanisation d'impunité où l'on pouvait
stigmatiser les forces de l'ordre les
accuser les soupçonner d'absence de
probité et finalement tout ceci
favorise un terreau ou prospère la haine
anti-flic et même la banalisation de la
violence à leur rencontre je voulais
avoir votre avis sur ce sujet
je vous passe la parole
j'évoquais le contexte historique de ces
phénomènes nous pourrions évoquer le
contexte historique du rejet par ultra
gauche de la police le mot hakab la
chronique accab n'est pas né en juin
2020 même si vous avez envie de le
souhaiter
nous sommes moins de ce sujet là je
reprendrai volontiers votre propos quand
vous dites les policiers ont jeté leur
menottes à terre il y a eu 1% de
policiers 1500 sur 150 000 qui ont eu
l'occasion d'exprimer non pas sous forme
de grève mais d'exprimer à
mécontentement et une condamnation de
mes propos tels que je les avais tenu le
8 juin 2020 et je voudrais vous rappeler
le contenu de cette conférence de presse
elle visait trois objets le premier
c'est à la réforme de l'IGPN dont je
pense que elle ne doit pas être figée
sur elle-même et d'ailleurs elle a été
en partie réformée le deuxième c'était
tolérance zéro contre le racisme dans la
police et je n'ai jamais dit que la
police était raciste est bien souvent ça
m'a été reproché mais je dis parce que
il peut arriver que dans la police il y
a du racisme et je pense que quand on
porte l'uniforme sur ce sujet aucun acte
raciste n'est tolérable et puis un
troisième sujet qui concernait les
techniques d'interpellation comme la clé
d'étranglement et je souhaitais
interdire la clé des tremblements que le
président Trump avait fait aux
États-Unis j'ai pas l'impression qu'il
soit totalement laxiste que la
pénitentiaire avait fait depuis une
vingtaine d'années alors que vous savez
que dans la pénitentiaire il n'y a que
les moyens physiques en cas de conflits
pour intervenir et c'était interdit et
que la gendarmerie avait interdit depuis
2010 je crois et c'est sur ces trois
sujets qu'il y a eu une expression
syndicale et je vous dis 1% de policiers
qui ont manifesté leur désaccord je ne
crois pas que la grande démission et je
reprends vos mots qui est un phénomène
un mot qui vient des États-Unis
d'Amérique suite au covid ne soit lié à
mes propos de juin 2020
je pense que aucun policier ou gendarme
de ce pays notaire et nous trouverait
anormal de ne pas tolérer le racisme
et aucun policier ne souhaite utiliser
des techniques qui prennent le risque de
le voir lui-même mis en cause parce
qu'une personne meurt et c'est ce qui
est arrivé sous mon autorité avec
Cédric chouvia qui par une technique qui
a été peut-être mal utilisée à ce
moment-là et mort à un moment
d'intervention et je peux vous dire que
il est la première victime mais que les
policiers eux-mêmes sont victimes d'un
système qui les a amenés à utiliser une
pratique qui était légale mais qui est
dangereuse en soi
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre donc
monsieur Caron ensuite monsieur maddesse
puis monsieur taverne donc monsieur
caronjo vous en prie merci monsieur le
Président
Monsieur le Ministre bref préambule
d'abord j'ai cru vous entendre tout à
l'heure amalgamer le multi condamné
raciste Éric Zemmour et la France
insoumise comme étant à vos yeux des
dangers dans le paysage politique
d'Angers pour la démocratie je note
d'ailleurs au passage que vous prenez
soin d'épargner Marine Le Pen ce qui est
un petit peu surprenant mais surtout
surtout je vous mets au défi de trouver
dans les propos de la France insoumise
le moindre mot le moindre appel qui soit
une atteinte aux valeurs de la
République française
on dit
le rassemblement national qui voudrait
donner des leçons aujourd'hui on aura
tout vu cela étant dit j'en viens
l'objet de notre commission les
violences dans les manifestations vous
avez expliqué la nouvelle doctrine de
maintien de l'ordre accroître la
réactivité la mobilité et donc elle est
au contact impacté comme on dit les
manifestants c'est à dire le rentrer
dedans pour être clair sont délicatesse
je rappelais d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
lors de l'audition précédente que vous
avez démis de cette fonction le préfet
Delpech parce que vous considériez à
l'époque que justement il faisait preuve
lui doit être
d'un manque de fermeté dans dans la
manière de gérer les manifestations il
n'était pas assez assez violent
peut-être parfois à vos yeux mais vous
dites aussi vous avez dit tout à l'heure
nous n'avons pas abandonné la doctrine
de maintien de l'ordre à distance en
l'absence de violence les forces de
l'ordre encadrent les manifestants et
donc ne charge pas or dans cette
commission mes collègues le savent j'ai
eu l'occasion de rappeler à maintes
reprises les nombreuses violences
gratuites documenté qu'on subit des
manifestants absolument pacifiques de la
part de force de l'ordre encore
aujourd'hui nouvelle information la LDH
vient de sortir un rapport j'arrive
c'est important parce que c'est l'objet
de notre commission un rapport sur les
violences assez solide sur lesquelles
nous enquêtons ce rapport est accablant
pour les autorités puisque par exemple
le président de ladh nous dit que les
rapports de la préfète des Deux-Sèvres
et celui directeur général de la
gendarmerie nationale présente des
éléments factuellement faux et
constituent selon nous une réécriture
des événements on peut même dire qu'il y
a eu de leur part une volonté de tromper
l'opinion publique car contrairement à
ce que ces deux rapports avancent à
s'insuline ce sont les forces de l'ordre
qui ont initié les hostilités ma
question est donc la suivante comment
expliquer vous monsieur le ministre
c'est violence répétées documentées des
forces de l'ordre contre des
manifestants pacifiques est-ce que ça
veut dire que la doctrine de maintien de
l'ordre est mal comprise est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'il y a des ordres mauvais
qui sont passés ou alors tout simplement
est-ce qu'il y a un problème dans le
recrutement des forces de l'ordre qui
sont chargées d'encadrer ces
manifestations
passe la parole merci je reviens sur les
deux premières remarques politiques j'ai
pas de Marine Le Pen on se connaît pas
monsieur Caron mais je pense que mon
combat politique personnelle a toujours
été à l'avant-garde du combat contre
Marine Le Pen et l'extrême droite et le
Front National et le rassemblement
national aujourd'hui j'ai pas beaucoup
de leçons à recevoir de quelqu'un qui
siège dans un groupe avec un collègue
député à la fille qui a été élu contre
moi sur demande de Marine Le Pen et de
Monsieur Louis à Lyon je suis le seul
député de France pour lequel Marine Le
Pen et lui a lieu ont appelé un faire
battre et à voter à la fille je pense
que pour vous
non mais je parle monsieur monsieur
Caron monsieur Carron il est inutile ne
vous énervez pas
monsieur Caron monsieur carrant non mais
monsieur mais alors c'est factuellement
monsieur Caron c'est factuel
personnellement en me reprochant de ne
pas avoir mis en cause Marine Le Pen je
vous réponds je vous réponds mais je
vais venir rassurez-vous je vous réponds
précisément sur le fait que je suis un
député sortant battu par un candidat LFI
qui d'ailleurs a diffusé sur les réseaux
sociaux l'appel à me faire battre de
Marine Le Pen et je vais vous dire j'en
ai jamais voulu à Marine Le Pen et à
louer à Lyon parce que dans la vie
politique faut assumer ses combats j'ai
toujours mené le combat sans
compromission contre l'extrême droite le
rassemblement national le Front National
et Marine Le Pen notamment dans ma
région prendront sa côte d'Azur en me
retirant des élections régionales en
2015 pour empêcher Marion Maréchal-Le
Pen d'être présidente de ma région et je
trouve normal du coup que une ligne
politique contre laquelle je suis battu
est à plein de faire battre mais j'ai
pas de leçon à recevoir quand je vois le
résultat de cela quant à savoir quant à
savoir quand à savoir je ne trouverai
jamais aucun mot chacun quant à savoir
si je ne trouverai jamais aucun mot ou
aucun quand je trouve quand à savoir si
je ne trouverai jamais aucun mot ou
aucun propos de la France insoumise que
je peux lier la radicalisation du débat
je vais juste vous citer ces phrases
la conquête de l'hégémonie politique a
un préalable il faut tout
conflictualiser tout conflictualisé tout
doit être interpellé tout doit être
conflictualisé dans un premier temps
c'est ça les leçons comment croyez ou
qu'on transforme un pote un peuple
révolté en un peuple révolutionnaire
comment sa conscience peut-elle
s'éveiller par les discours bien sûr
mais par la pratique de la lutte moi je
n'appartiens pas à une famille politique
qui pense qu'il faut tout
conflictualiser je répète tout
conflictualiser
alors si vous voulez
et encore moins à l'apaisement et
surtout quand on fait la distinction
face surtout non mais c'est attendez
vous m'interpellez sur des phrases dont
je considère parce que je reprends mes
mots précisément je disais la
conflictualisation vous avez répondu à
mes mots mais mot était lesquels non pas
ceux que vous pensez avoir entendu oui
j'ai dit la conflictualisation
permanente du discours de la France
insoumise n'est pas sans effet non plus
et bien je vous le redis les yeux dans
les yeux quand à votre question vous
voulez vous convaincre que la violence
est par nature celle de la police moi
par expérience je sais que la violence
est par nature celle de ceux qui
viennent dans les manifestations pour se
confronter directement aux forces de
sécurité intérieure pour leur lancer des
bombes d'acide pour la relancer des
cocktails Molotov ou qui veulent casser
et dans ce cadre là
les forces de sécurité insert sont les
seuls légitimes à utiliser la force ce
doit être proportionné et je l'ai
toujours dit comme ministre de
l'intérieur quand il y a des fautes il
peut y en avoir elles doivent être
sanctionnées
merci beaucoup monsieur Mendes je vous
en prie
merci monsieur le Président et bonsoir
monsieur le ministre
excusez-moi j'étais un peu perturbé par
ce qui vient de se passer je voulais
revenir sur ce que vous avez vécu à
l'époque en tant que ministre de
l'Intérieur si je ne dis pas de bêtises
place de la République à Paris lors de
un démantèlement d'un camp sauvage qui
avait été imposé par des élus et des
associations d'ultra gauche et de gauche
avec certains élus qui étaient présents
avec leur écharpe et qui a le contact
des agents de police si vous pouvez nous
faire un nous rappeler le comment vous
avez vécu les choses en interne
puisqu'on sait que c'est compliqué pour
les agents de police de pouvoir
intervenir facilement face à des élus
qui portent leur écharpe et qui viennent
au contact du plexiglas de ces agents on
l'a vu les images donc je fais que
rappeler ce qui s'était passé et quel
est votre point de vue aujourd'hui quand
on voit les manifestations de ce
week-end ou certains de élus de la
France insoumise et d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts ce pavaner écharpe bleu blanc
rouge sur eux au cri de
tout le monde déteste la police
alors la manifestation enfin
l'intervention dont vous parlez je crois
lui en juillet 2020 mais je n’étais plus
ministre de l'Intérieur et donc je ne
peux pas la commenter mais je sais qu'il
est difficile pour les forces de
sécurité quand elles doivent faire
appliquer la loi d'être confronté à des
élus à des membres de la représentation
nationale parce qu'effectivement ils
savent que c'est dans le monde tension
supplémentaire je sais que l'exercice
est plus difficile mais je peux pas
répondre soit en fait deuxième question
qui sort de notre discussion mais qui
est plus politique j'ai pu observer cela
je vais prendre le un peu le contre-pied
moi je ne suis pas
totalement choqué par le fait que des
élus puissent dire qu'ils ne partagent
pas même une décision de justice dans la
fonction d'élus ça n'est pas le cas pour
l'exécutif même si sur une manifestation
interdite par contre je pense que la
dignité d'un élu aurait été de quitter
immédiatement cette manifestation quand
ils entendent l'écrit de tout le monde
déteste la police à la fois par éthique
par morale mais aussi parce que quand on
représente notre pays on est censé
s'intéresser à l'opinion publique et
chacun sait que les forces de sécurité
intérieure sont largement soutenus dans
notre pays
merci beaucoup il y avait une demande de
prise de parole monsieur taverne donc je
vous passe la parole et puis ensuite
monsieur Odoul
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
l'arbre-temps monsieur ministre
tout d'abord je voudrais quand même
rappeler le ras-le-bol des policiers
comme ma collègue a dit Diaz la évoqué
il y a quasiment 10000 démissions c'est
un rapport de la Cour des comptes donc
ensuite il y a forcément une présomption
de culpabilité des policiers et puis on
a entendu le ministre de l'Intérieur à
dire que oui effectivement ils sont pas
trop diplômés donc bon
faire avec il faut essayer de les former
du mieux possible pour le coup il a
raison mais dans les faits c'est ce
n'est pas fait
concernant le maintien de l'ordre vous
avez effectivement rappelé le retrait de
la grenade lacrymogène instantanée la
Gly F4
durant nos auditions les policiers les
gendarmes ont été clair c'est-à-dire que
au fur et à mesure du temps plus les
violences étaient importantes dans les
manifestations c'est à dire les
violences exercées contre les forces de
l'ordre
et moi ils avaient de moyen c'est-à-dire
que au fur et à mesure du temps leurs
moyens étaient retirés donc on a évoqué
la GLI
on évoque également la la méthode
d'étranglement et clairement à la
méthode d'étranglement dans le contexte
police n'existe pas
donc à chaque fois quand il y a
malheureusement un fait on enlève une
technique et puis aux États-Unis bon
effectivement mais parce qu'ils
utilisent beaucoup plus de moyens
intermédiaires notamment le pistolet sur
électrique donc c'est en fait ce sont
deux contextes complètement différents
ensuite concernant le lanceur de balle
de défense effectivement
sous votre autorité mise en place de
superviseurs le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui être superviseur c'est
extrêmement compliqué donc en fait comme
disait le professeur Alain Bauer c'est à
dire qu'on écoute la hiérarchie mais les
policiers de terrain qui ont une
technique ou une stratégie ou une vision
en fait on les écoute pas on les méprise
donc je pense que c'est ce qui a été
fait pendant pendant quelques années
et notamment aujourd'hui dans les
violences plusieurs milliers de
policiers blessés
plusieurs milliers également de
gendarmes blessés notamment par le soit
le retrait de deux moyens dit
intermédiaires donc aujourd'hui pour
vous qu'elle serait véritablement
la technique à adopter par rapport à ces
groupes muscules violents
soit les à l'impact donc à la percussion
pour essayer les disloquer comme vous
l'avez dit à juste titre mais les
techniques françaises veulent et c'est
ce qui fait notre renommée que on garde
à distance mais le problème c'est que
plus on enlève de moyens moins on a la
possibilité de garder la distance et
puis nous avons de policiers blessé
parce qu'en face ils utilisent des
engins exposés improvisés etc ils
n'hésitent pas à utiliser des vraiment
des des moyens
extrêmement dangereux donc pour vous
quel est votre votre stratégie qu'on
pourrait adopter justement pour garder
cette distance en utilisant les moyens
appropriés pour les groupuscules
violents merci
avec des primes de revalorisation des
salaires notamment pour le CEA 130 euros
en moyenne par mois et je sais que
Gérald Darmanin a poursuivi cela et à
même obtenu des budgets que le ministre
du Budget de l'époque négociait avec le
ministre de l'Intérieur que j'étais et
obtenu des budgets qui permettent
aujourd'hui de remonter le niveau je
pense qu'il faut continuer cet effort et
c'est le cadre de la l'optique à
présenter le mis de l'intérieur et que
vous avez je crois adopter enfin que
vous avez adopté j'ai pas regardé qui a
voté quoi ça n'est pas mon sujet
aujourd'hui mais je pense que c'est
important ensuite il faut réaffirmer
notre confiance dans la police mais la
confiance est-ce que pas d'exigence mais
aussi des évolutions je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous sur le fait d'avoir
une nostalgie pour la clé d'étranglement
je pense que si la quasi-totalité des
polices du monde alors dictature ne
pratique pas la clé d'étranglement c'est
parce qu'elle présente le dangerosité et
je le dis même pour les hommes et les
femmes qui doivent l'utiliser il est bon
de les en protéger parce qu'il y a rien
de pire au moment d'une interpellation
comme ça
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure d'imaginer
que on a causé le décès d'un homme et je
pense aussi à la dimension personnelle
pour le policier pour l'équipe de
policiers qui interviennent pour tout le
monde et donc faut trouver ce point
d'équilibre mais il faut pas les
déséquiper il faut pas les désarmer et
je n'ai jamais utilisé je pense qu'il ne
devait pas être tenu ensuite il y a une
contradiction dans votre question ou un
petit mélange je veux pas polémiquer
même si ça va mettre au crochet parce
que je peux
le sujet
vous mélangez un peu entre
l'intervention sur un Black Box c'est la
distance que je dis c'est que la
stratégie celle de la distance par
contre faut percuter le Black Bloc là
c'est une percutation physique et on va
au contact et nous savons quand nous
sommes ministres de l'Intérieur que en
allant sur cette technique on augmente
le risque de de blesser et donc mais
nous pensons que c'est la bonne chose
par contre
ça peut là une question de moyens parce
qu'on n'est pas quand on a percuté avec
le LBD quand on va percuter c'est pas
avec des moyens ou des grenades de type
Glee ou celle qui la remplacé c'est une
percutation physique ma préconisation
elle est liée au renforcement du
renseignement global renforcement du
renseignement sur ces sujets il faut
encore le faire monter en puissance sur
les Ultra au sens large mais elle est
aussi effectivement de renforcer les
moyens y compris de type véhicule et je
pense que les engins lanceurs d'eau sur
la gestion de ces manifestations qui
dérapent sont une bonne préconisation
mais surtout elle est le principe de
spécialité et c'est la volonté conduite
par l'actuel ministre de l'Intérieur et
dans l'esprit du schéma national de
maintien de l'ordre que nous avions
préparé avec Laurent Nunez qui est en
vigueur aujourd'hui qui est celle de
faire en sorte que soit les unités
spécialisées parce que les policiers je
reprends votre propos global du début
qui sont sur le terrain
en bac ne sont pas les plus habilités
pour intervenir sur le maintien de
l'ordre et c'est aussi parce que on a
affaibli notre dispositif du maintien de
l'ordre notamment les escadrons qui a
perdu un quart de leurs effectifs enfin
les sur les territoires les CRS à peu
près les mêmes proportions et donc du
coup là on a diminué le nombre de CRS
dans une compagnie on a diminué le
nombre de gendarmes dans un escadron et
donc on a affaibli le dispositif je
pense qu'il faut remonter le niveau
de capacitaire sur la gestion de l'ordre
public sachant que un policier dans une
CRS ou un gendarme dans un escadron ne
fait pas que de l'ordre public et que
s'il n'y a pas de désordre public ce que
nous appelons tous de nos vœux ils
peuvent parfaitement intervenir sous
l'autorité des préfets pour faire de la
sécurité publique ils le font bien aussi
merci beaucoup monsieur le monsieur
Odoul je vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur monsieur Castaner j'aimerais
en préambule réagir à votre appréciation
de l'Assemblée nationale vous avez parlé
de champs de guerre je tiens à vous
rappeler très simplement que la semaine
nationale c'est d'abord le chant de la
démocratie quel que soit
les idées les opinions qui peut-être
vous déplaisent quel que soit les les
divergences que nous avons dans cette
salle nous sommes ici parce que le
peuple souverain l'a décidé et c'est
aussi le peuple souverain qui a décidé
de ne pas vous reconduire c'est ni
Marine Le Pen il ou Ayo ce sont les
électeurs de votre circonscription
ensuite je voulais revenir dans le
prolongement de la question de ma
collègue Edwige Diaz sur finalement la
responsabilité de votre ministère et de
vos déclarations nous parlons dans cette
position d'enquête de manifestations
interdites et pourtant autorisé
c'est-à-dire que la loi n'est pas
respectée c'est à dire que l'autorité
administrative et
isolé et c'est vrai que tout est parti
de cette fameuse manifestation de juin
donc vous avez parlé d'émotions
internationales vous avez eu cette
phrase malheureuse l'émotion dépasse les
règles juridiques
et c'est vrai que si on part de ce
postulat là tout est possible toutes les
infractions sont possibles c'est la
porte ouverte à tout et n'importe quoi
et finalement ça exonère
tout citoyen d'une responsabilité et
surtout du respect élémentaire de la loi
de la République et sur ces
manifestations d'ailleurs que vous avez
un peu balayé avec beaucoup de légèreté
en disant que c'était des jeunes en
disant que c'était à la suite du meurtre
de Georges le Floyd vous avez tout à
l'heure été ému des slogans tout le
monde était la police je vous invite à
revoir les vidéos de cette fameuse
manifestation ou des milliers de
personnes scandaient tout le monde
déteste la police je vous ai entendu
vous en offusquez à l'époque et ou
d'ailleurs où c'était pas de simples
jeunes qui manifestait mais le comité
Traoré bien organisé pour cracher comme
il le fait régulièrement sur les forces
de l'ordre et les serviteurs de la
République donc moi ma question c'est
très simple c'est est-ce que vous
regrettez cette petite phrase qui
finalement aujourd'hui
légitime des infractions légitimes
l'organisation de manifestations
interdite puisque finalement quand les
responsables politiques ne sont pas
capables de faire respecter la loi comme
ça a été votre cas mais effectivement ça
encourage les fauteurs de troubles à
l'enfer je vous remercie
pardon
la parole merci le président d'abord je
suis un citoyen libre et donc mes
commentaires sur l'ancien n'engage que
moi mais je suis un citoyen libre à qui
il arrive de regarder ce qui se passe
dans l'Assemblée nationale et je pense
que
mon opinion exprimait tout à l'heure est
assez révélatrice de l'opinion de
beaucoup d'observateurs de ce qui s'y
passe et je le regrette et je pense que
les parlementaires doivent aussi le
regretter sauf si il considère que de la
chiot lit n'est un accès au pouvoir mais
je pense que là je suis en ligne n'est
pas la meilleure façon de préserver la
démocratie je reprends volonté au mot
manifestations interdites et pourtant
autorisées
vous avez à la fois un problème de droit
et à la fois un problème de mémoire un
problème de droit c'est que cette
formule ne veut strictement rien dire
parce qu'à aucun moment cette
manifestation a été autorisée par contre
un ministre de l'Intérieur est confronté
à une question simple peut-il l'empêcher
quand vous avez 30 000 personnes qui
viennent sur une manifestation vous
pouvez décider de faire appel à l'armée
vous pouvez décider d'encercler Paris de
couper le périphérique et d'imaginer les
moyens absolument exceptionnels pour
l'empêcher ou alors vous pouvez chercher
à avoir une réponse proportionnelle qui
prend en compte l'émotion du moment et
l'émotion de la jeunesse et dans cette
émotion du moment il y avait aussi la
sortie du confinement je l'ai aborder
tout à l'heure vous sembler ne pas
l'avoir entendu mais ça faisait partie
des éléments de contexte et je pense que
l'intelligence politique c'est pas de
s'appuyer sur une doctrine ou sur un
dogme mais c'est au contraire de prendre
en compte les éléments factuels d'une
situation et de donner le bon ordre
peut-être que le ministre de l'Intérieur
aurait pu à ce moment-là demander à
toutes les forces de sécurité intérieure
de venir sur Paris et de charger
c'est ce qu'avait fait certains
responsables politiques à certains
moments et c'est ce qui a pu générer un
grand nombre de morts dans les
manifestations et je peux vous dire que
quand vous êtes ministre de l'Intérieur
vous n'êtes pas un commentateur vous
êtes celui qui doit se poser cette seule
question d'éviter absolument une
escalade de gravité et des morts et donc
ce jour-là je considère que nous
n'étions pas en capacité d'empêcher la
manifestation dans des conditions
pourraient garanties la sécurité de ceux
qui venaient manifester mais aussi de
ceux qui étaient dans le palais de
justice c'est cela dont on parle alors
ensuite vous pouvez polémiquer mais non
seulement vous faites aussi une erreur
historique après avoir fait une erreur
de droit l'erreur historique est de
penser que les désordres dont on parle
aurait commencé en juin 2020 la même
erreur que vous faites en disant que
c'est le comité Traoré qui organise
cette manifestation ça n'était
absolument pas le cas le comité Traoré
avait organisé une motivation le samedi
suivant et un ou deux samedi d'après
mais absolument pas sur cette
manifestation
et pour ce qui est de savoir si j'avais
à l'époque eu l'occasion de condamner le
tout le monde déteste la police je l'ai
fait très régulièrement il m'aime
arriver de porter plainte sur ces sujets
y compris d'ailleurs contre Jean-Luc
Mélenchon quand il a vu une expression
sur la police que je ne trouvais pas
acceptable où j'avais fait un article 40
sur ce sujet et donc là aussi je pense
que on peut se faire plaisir mais on
peut aussi regarder la réalité en face
et penser que quand vous êtes en
responsabilité une décision doit prendre
en compte des éléments de contexte et je
vais vous dire c'est ce que font chaque
jour chaque nuit les 250 000 gendarmes
et policiers de notre pays il n'applique
pas une doctrine bête et méchante ils
font preuve d'intelligence il faudrait
que chacun essaye
merci beaucoup monsieur ministre donc
mes chers collègues nous allons clore
cette cette audition nous nous
retrouvons dès demain pour deux autres
auditions pour information elle se
dérouleront juste à côté en salle de la
commission des finances donc qui est
voisine à celle-ci je vous remercie
bonne soirée à toutes et à tous